bonjour patricia saint-aulaye bonjour
bertrand carrez vous êtes délégué
territorial pour le sauvetage en mer
qu'est ce qui vous a valu d'être nommée
première femme délégué territorial pour
le sauvetage en mer dans toute la france
c'est à souligner absolument j'ai eu ce
privilège alors c'est très simplement un
client qui paie le président de la
station du françois qui m'a sollicité
j'ai mis à peu près trois mois pour
prendre une décision parce que c'est
c'est une belle c'est une très très
belle mission mais ce n'est pas
n'importe quelle mission
c'est un défi aussi mais c'est un défi
et c'est surtout sauver des vies donc
j'ai réfléchi quand j'ai vu qu'elle
était l'importance puisque la martinique
est entouré de mer et l'importance de
sauver des vies d'accompagner de
prévenir et de forme et je me suis dit
que ce défi ge
il était le mien non non et aujourd'hui
je rentre d'amande ans est cet habit qui
m'a été proposé que je découvre avec
beaucoup de bonheur il faut savoir que
le préfet de la martinique est
responsable de 3 millions de kilomètres
carrés de l'intelligence sur le littoral
donc c'est de toutes petites îles qui
qui gère cette surveillance immense et
c'est une fierté pour nous les
martiniquaises et des martiniquais
alors dites que vous découvrez
effectivement cette nouvelle mission
parce que vous avez été nommé en juillet
dernier un absolu à ce poste à cette
fonction de délégué territorial du
sauvetage en mer alors le sauvetage en
mer c'est en france un réseau national
qui se décline sur chacun des
territoires et en l'occurrence pour nous
ça se décline en quatre stations
autonome absolument décrivez nous serons
alors la délégation de la vente unique
est doté d'un président qui nous met par
le siège à paris sur la martinique nous
avons quatre stations une station à
fort-de-france une ak ce pilote une au
françois et une aux marins chaque
station est autonome et le siège nomme
un président qui responsable donc de la
station du déroulement de des actions du
fonctionnement de la station
un patron qui est responsable de la
flotte de l'équipement et de des
équipiers et un trésorier
donc ce sont trois personnages qui sont
nommés par par le siège alors quatre
stations dont une à fort de france une à
case-pilote une eau françois et une aux
marins absolument c'est bien cela tout
ça ça repose sur du bénévolat
une centaine de bénévoles en martinique
il faut faire fonctionner tout ça avec
cette mission majeure donc vous le
disiez de sauver des vies quand elles
sont en péril sur sur la mer et donc
vous fait appel aussi beaucoup aux dons
et legs
aux partenariats avec des entreprises
enfin du mécénat oui merci de préciser
cela parce que souvent nous sommes
assimilés à des services de l'état et
nous ne sommes pas du tout dépendant de
l'état même si nous avons
un déclenchement par par le cross mais
je pense qu'on en parlera tout à l'heure
nous sommes des bénévoles oui plus de
100 bénévoles sur la martinique et nous
ne vivons que des dons des legs et de
des événements que nous pouvons créer
avec avec les les bonnes volontés
oui c'est important et il y a aussi une
chose c'est que nous le sauvetage en mer
est totalement gratuit nous n'avons pas
le droit de
de demander un financement sur la vie
sur le rendu aux personnes qui sont sous
public
il faut le savoir parce que les ont
souvent peur de faire appel à aux
sauveteurs en mer parce qu'ils se disent
que ça va ils vont payer qu'il est que
et que mais ils n'auront pas la
possibilité d'avoir accès à ce service
ce service est gratuit
maintenant au niveau des embarcations il
y a parfois des embarcations on se
souvient de ce qui s'est passé sur le
tour des yoles à la beach créé à la
mercury beach pardon est sûre si ses
prestations là nous avons la possibilité
de faire quelques je dis bien quelques
remorquage parce que sur la martinique
aujourd'hui vous avez des structures qui
sont qu'ils sont
à même de faire de remorquage et nous
travaillons donc en collaboration
également avec les pompiers quand nous
sommes appelés sur des opérations comme
celle ci met alors sur le remorquage oui
nous avons une prestation payante pour
ramener le bateau mais quand on dit
prestations payantes
si le bal al le bateau et assurer la
prestation est prise en compte par
l'assurance
par l'assurance mais cette danse arcady
avec notre invité patrice hyacinthe au
lof délégué territorial pour le
sauvetage en mer
on parlait de bénévolat est ce qu'il ya
quand même des emplois qui sont liées à
votre action de sauvetage alors c'est
mon souhait le plus cher parce que quand
j'ai pris la responsabilité de cette
délégation
on est on est très complémentaire avec
mon prédécesseur c'est à dire que lui il
était beaucoup plus sur le terrain en
mer moi je suis beaucoup plus sur
l'administratif et les finances donc oui
on sera en mesure de vous présenter en
début d'année la lame la configuration
que la délégation de martinique met en
place donc vous allez vous vous et au
fait vous renforcer dans votre action un
cent à s'étoffer doit comprendre des
mois alors vous avez également d une
mission de formation forcément il faut
il faut former les les sauveteurs enfin
les différents intervenants dans ses
missions
on a la chance d'en 2015 d'avoir un pôle
de formation antilles qui a été créé en
2011 le pôle de saint nazaire a été créé
mais nous en 2015 nous avons notre pôle
qui a été créé il est institué en
guadeloupe et nous travaillons nous
travaillons avec ce pôle délégation de
guadeloupe et délégation de martinique
effectivement pour mettre en place des
sessions de formation nos sessions de
formation sont organisés en interne et
peuvent être organisées aussi en externe
on peut faire des opérations avec les
pompiers la gendarmerie le samu
voilà on va rappeler rapidement quel est
le public qui est visé par le sauvetage
en mer on pense évidemment par exemple
de manière très évidente aux marins
pêcheurs
vous y avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
mais il ya certainement d'autres
catégories de public
là on rappelle que pour déclencher un
secours en mer il faut appeler le cross
absolument que le crossman alors en
terre
c'est le numéro d'appel d'urgence et le
196 et en mer c'est le canal 19 oui nous
nous agissons dès que nous sommes
sollicité pour les plaisanciers les
pêcheurs les transforme à tous qui tout
ce qui circule sur la sur la mer vous
avez deux pôles que vous voulez
développé par rapport à ce qui se passe
depuis quelques années des cyclones de
plus en plus intense par exemple c'est
le ravitaillement et l'aide matérielle
oui c'est important aujourd'hui et nous
sommes nous sommes en train de préparer
des sessions de formation pour ceux pour
ses difficultés que nous pouvons nous
avons été nous rappelons que nous avons
été présents lors de irma sur
saint-martin nous avons fait d'un
ravitaillement et nous sommes l'équipe
les quatre stations se sont regroupés
pour pouvoir partir sur saint martin et
venir en aide
donc ça c'est un paul qui va qui va se
développer absolue renforcée en a besoin
nouvelle vedette aussi eu pour le
sauvetage en mer a dit oui j'ai dit que
c'est mon bébé basque agile et mon
prédécesseur
mam a laissé
une très très belle
arrivé une très belle naissance c'est la
naissance de la vedette la sra 716 de
case-pilote d'ailleurs nous allons faire
des démonstrations le 17 novembre
puisque nous participons à la fête de la
mer de bellefontaine
ce samedi nous participons
à la l'organisation que la préfecture a
mis pour la sécurité nous serons sur le
front de mer de fort de france
donc j'invite les martiniquaises et les
martiniquais à venir nous rencontrer
nous allons faire des présentations de
l'hélitreuillage et un programme quand
même assez conséquent ouais voilà bah on
va conclure peut-être une information
pratique oui presque 7h30 et c'est déjà
la fin de la vie de cet entretien de
cette interview
alors les contactera paix comment il
faut faire s'il ya des numéros à donner
alors je rappelle que le numéro
d'urgence et le 196 que en mer sauvetage
en mer et pour la délégation vous pouvez
joindre la délégation de la martinique
ou 800 707 06 100 96 800 707 et le même
cd des traits d'union martinique
@ snsm point org merci patrice hyacinthe
olympe délégué territorial du sauvetage
en mer en martinique eu une bonne
journée
merci bonne journée
[Musique]